I'm super excited being here speaking
for pi data Global online today's
session will be about how to build llm
applications not application more like
large language model applications
without weor databases without storage
like we focusing on more how to bring to
llm application streaming data let me
introduce myself first a little bit for
those who doesn't know me my name is
again babour or you can call me tiger
which is in English I'm a Dev advocate
for pathway also for for a while for
Microsoft for leading inop audience for
aure and now is also I'm contributing to
some of the open source project under
the Apache softway Foundation today's
session will be about uh starting with
some of the GPT limitations uh we are
focusing on some of the solutions
existing in the market how we can bring
the context to AI responses and most of
you know already because we are python
developers nowadays is one of the how
say the hyping topic who is dealing with
a lot lot of like data for llms and I'm
also going to introduce our open source
project called llm application that
helps you to build this AI application
without woring about some infrastru
infrastructure and costs and so on you
will understand as the end of the
presentation what it is and I GNA show
you short demo at the end of the session
how we can achieve this without any
Vector storage and having the AI
application is up and and running so
today's everyone is talking about AI or
artificial intelligence but much of the
talks mainly falls into one of two in
extremes as you can see on the slide AI
gonna fix everything or AI will most
probably win everything we'll see how
the times comes in the future but
uh actually the one of the example good
examples open AI gp4 powerful llm right
use it for wide range of NLP tasks and
CH GPT also set the records of fastest
growing user base in January 2023 and
that proves that the large language
models are staying here longer than we
expected even longer than uh bit Bitcoin
the blockchain or maybe web stre
technology it's not like hype anymore
many companies they applying and
bringing uh real word solutions by using
the AIS so and myself also as a python
developer I decided to build my own
application let me show you this
application what about quickly
summarizing the content get information
that you need in real time from your
private large unstructured documents in
your Dropbox so you can just ask some
questions from multiple documents exist
in your Dropbox or the same tool you can
use for one drive or Google Drive
depending on which Google provider or
let's say the document Drive provider
you using it helps you to retrieve
necessary information because sometimes
you are looking for some PDFs which are
maybe more than 100 Pages it's so
difficult to find relevant information
but if you're using this tool your life
will be easier at the end of the demo
you will see how this application works
uh what about also another AI
application I built to find the real
time discounts deals sales prices from
various online markets around the world
for example I can search for night shoes
from Amazon products I can specify my
size and what I'm looking for into AI
chat and it can respond me and find the
discounts in real time this is how
combination of real time information and
AI comes into picture and then also yet
another showcase I have think about an
application that provides real time
alerts for any significant changes or
updates in marketing campaigns let's say
your system can monitor lots of
information such as content when content
changes or campaign performance metrics
or maybe you change the date of your
campaign and it really affects on the
future marketing performance so you will
get a real time alerts as soon as
marketing some data changes in your
documents and the same concept can be
applied in many cases right when you are
changing some data and you are getting
real time alerts with the llms and yet
another last showcase I have what about
like without any much effort extracting
organizing unstructured data from like
PDFs dogs Powerpoints and put this
unstructured data into structured SQL
tables in real time this is also one of
the examples I provided this gift this
example exactly extracts data from unst
files and stores it into post SQL table
it also transforms the user quir into
SQL which then executed of course in the
post SQL tables so you can see all these
examples uh by going to our giab
reposter you will find at end of this
presentation the qu code check out all
these four showcases and to they can be
a foundation for you to build your own a
application the same alerts for example
like LM application alerting feature can
be also used for monitoring the model
performance when for example llms can
sometimes produce unexpected undesirable
outputs and you can receive some alerts
or in case your llms are used for
processing sensitive data real time
alerting can be also useful for security
and compliance cases in case if some
security information use it you can send
the Aller to the team or security team
to identify these leakages so if that
sounds good so let's start with some of
the challenges I faced during
preparation of this AI application for
example GPT was even if famous but there
are some problems with CPT it cannot
answer your unfamiliar questions because
it doesn't know I am based in Estonia in
Talon I'm speaking to you online because
it has no context that one of the
biggest problem and it has no real- time
data Let's test it B the example of this
finding discounts I Tred to find a
specific discount this week actually
this week is very key key word right
because we don't know exactly when this
discounts available because AI doesn't
know it and I tried to test it before
building my application just using this
CH GPT interface as you can see it can
answer just general advice by giving
general advice on how to locate the
discount but it lacks very specifically
regarding where are and what type of
discounts among other details we are
Miss missing and so to help the
application you we know all we are
applying from engineering so we put some
information discount information we
before we sent and ask GPT which where
we providing initial document right
prior to posting the actual questions
let me what I did I just uh retri with
the Json response from real Amazon
product API and I put on in the chat and
now as you expected this is quite simple
to achieve ggpt now can answer our
question but here the issue comes again
the bigger issue because the model
context is restricted unfortunately gp4
for example maximum text lengths around
8,192 tokens this strategy will quickly
become problematic when input data is
huge in reality you can expect a lot of
Longs of list of uh sales and discounts
available in the market if we're talking
about one market what think about many
markets around the world so and other
problems also we may you can face with
like a cost or maybe like a manual work
because we are just getting the data
manually and putting in the chat
interface but the biggest problems comes
even with the challenges productionizing
this I like this word by the way if you
like it also put in the comment because
there's a hug problems with
productionizing this llm application in
addition to to some problems with
ambiguity of natural languages they also
cause latency problems we think about
like if you are providing detailed
information examples in the chat or
using apis model performance might be
improved but at higher cost because you
are giving a lot of information and lot
of tokens being used and it escalates
the cost if you are not using any cash
system and repeating and repeatedly
asking the same question the same
question wents to the let open a API and
you are running out of budget so and
then uh let me see I don't see my camera
myself okay think about also latency one
of the challenges open AI APF for
example they don't have slas you never
know your response when it comes to your
system because there's no average time
there's also not guarantee when this
response available for example also it
makes it difficult for offline
evaluation like you cannot conduct
offline testes or test your code because
the data coming from llms always
different it's not the same so it makes
hard to challenging uh for developers to
test their application so in this
session I'm going to show some partial
answer the out say to the challenges how
you can resolve these challenges
partially not fully because not
everybody now is capable of solving all
this existing problems I listed out but
let's start from the beginning how we
can add our open data to llms we use CH
GPD interface as I did but it doesn't
work because I'm a developer I want to
hack something I want to write a code so
I will start with using the API so what
you do you just use some open source or
the paid providers L&M providers such as
open AI API they have usually two famous
apis one is embeddings next the chart
compilations what do you do just send
the input data to this open AI API
embance in point to calculate Vector
embeddings who for those who doesn't
know what the vector embeddings is just
the two points Vector points if the two
Vector points are close each other which
means they are related to each other if
they are a little bit longer each other
which means the distance is longer and
text are not the same to each other so
after we C vctor edings we send together
with quir prompt to completion and
points and most commonly architecture in
building this L IG AR architecture you
may know like ritual aent generation
architecture shows very simple
architecture what you do you are
building a data pipeline to build AI
application because everything is about
data pipeline if you don't have a
knowledge and how to build data pipeline
you are failing to build the Great AI
product so what you do you start with
ingesting data from apis files database
any sort of data source and you run this
data pipeline to Pro pre process filter
out some unnecessary data hide some uh
security data and you send this data as
I said to B point and after you
calculate this indexing you index vector
embeddings and you store to Vector
storage like a vector databases right
and then once you have this indexed
input data in the vector databases and
you start to build your own application
with a maybe beautiful UI that makes
searchable something and on UI side and
you have a backend application that
accepts some user quiries and also
calculates the vector embeddings and
does similarity search against a vector
database data and if you find some
similarities you start to build prom and
you you just s this PR the chart
completion endpoint the architecture is
very simple to achieve but if you think
about the Technologies to build this uh
simple architecture comes even difficult
you need to know you need to a a lot of
Technologies nowadays even new tools are
coming up because of AI wave we are not
uh it's difficult to catch up with the
new technologies so we decided with our
team starting August this year what if
we try to build some open source
solution for developers to make the
python developer especially easy without
having a knowledge how this architecture
all the technology in this architecture
works and without using multiple tools
maybe you can use one tool that combines
everything and you don't have to learn
everything together just learn one
technology and build your application
for example if you're using llm
application you can try to search out on
Google you will find on the first place
you don't need Vector databases because
it does realtime indexing uh it does
also real time quiry building and prompt
building and send this prompts to the CH
comption point which means you don't
even need some Frameworks like chain or
some redes like llm caches or API
Builders like a fast API because we
provide a fast AP API that maybe streams
data or even just returns HTTP response
so how this Things Fancy things Works
under the hood we had another project
called pathway which is also application
layer for python where you can run some
streaming data on the your data stays
where it is you can just run on the top
of of it some uh data processing
pipeline so if you combine this with the
existing new tool llm application which
is also framework for build a
application that helps you to build AI
data pipeline in real time so you can
bring real time information for your AI
application that makes also uh
simplification in other words like to
create your G project for example uh
which means means you have a shorter
time to go to market with a lower cost
with a high security and easily adopt
because you don't have to learn many uh
tools Technologies or some other
additional concept and of course you can
take a full power of streaming streaming
data processing tool like a pathway so
also we are improving with the community
to support and add more features to
inest as soon as as we are possible to
from different data sources like you can
inest nowadays some data from
unstructured data or semistructured data
or the live data uh depending on where
your data is living SE some of the key
features that we introduce like uh for
example we have as building connectors
for CSV files Json lines PDFs or apis so
you don't have to implement your
connector or you don't have to write any
code to connect uh to any data source so
in this case it makes some uh gives you
some flexibility and one of the key
features like as you saw alerting is a
very powerful uh I don't see like other
Technologies who is also doing this real
time alerting nowadays also one of the
features I like this user permissions
you think about like the roles because
for L applications roles are important
if let's say I'm building AI application
for HR System that generates report
about employees performance uh from the
past three months Mones and manager asks
like show me BB's performance last three
month because I need to do s review and
I'm asking for cellular rise but you
think about only my manager can see this
data if this system allows to to see
data for other employees it's going to
be a little bit conflict right I don't
want to that my colleagues know my
salary because there's going to be some
misunderstandings in this case user
permissions metadata can be also easily
uh manag it inside this fancy
application so from the architecture
wise look if you look at the slides in
the behind we had like a very complex
architecture for modern stack ANM
application this architecture looks
simpler uh because what we are doing we
are just building our front application
using any front end Frameworks I was
using stream L for example for my for UI
and then you can just bring this big
component with
customizable inside like you can
customize for example your embeddings
features you don't have to use your
embeddings externally like open a IPI or
you can also run your private L&M which
is finally tun it if you have enough
gpus why not uh so in this case as you
can see in this picture like we are
ingesting some real time data and we are
doing realtime indexing and also we are
doing some real time prompt engineering
and then also request as comes in you
don't have to wait until data gets
processed just you upload the data and
your data is available for search this
is one of the powerful in the python
wise the code is also looks very simple
as you can see it's with a few lines of
code you have a ready application as you
can see like for this discount
application we are trying to read some
CSV data let's assume that some CSV data
contains some discount information and
you doing you transforming this data how
you want to show how you want to Index
this data and we are calculating
embeddings again we are indexing and we
are waiting for the external quiry from
the user and we are combining this quir
with input data the same rack approach
but it's in real time that magic happens
on the bottom line if as you can see uh
PW which means pathway. one this uh runs
the loop as data comes in you do some
real time application let me show you
how it works for example building the
data pipelines uh using the pathway is
like you manipulating static and finite
data then when you get really big data
it's you can easily switch to streaming
mode from bch mode let's say you start
to develop in a static mode because you
don't want to like streaming because
it's makes the your life a little bit
hard to testing and then you can just
change one configur ation uh to make it
work for streaming you don't have to
rewrite your python code just write one
code and then you are good to go so also
what does mean for you you just only
build once your data pipeline so without
reputations and you need to also provide
some connectors plug these connectors uh
from the pathway on your data streams so
you just start to build your pipeline
with the python apis so also you can
also send this data to uh data streams
as output so this all is support by by
the passway engine whenever new data
points are received you can uh see the
output resulting tables to your end
application end application can be like
maybe also some cfco topics or even like
CSV files output and so on so with that
you can also try yourself check out the
ANM application report we are growing we
also calling for massive contribution if
you would like to contribute to our open
source project you are more than welcome
just by scanning this QR code get
yourself uh sort of get your knowledge
and then start to maybe help us with
some answering questions or maybe Rising
some additional the issues so and how
what about the pathway that others think
about us if you're looking look at the
examples use a pathway you just reduce
the latency if you're building any data
pipeline it's not about El applications
we are talking about streaming board and
it makes your data Engineers life also
little bit easier and if you want
especially like a real time data work
for you from the single day it's
achievable with a pathway so now it's
the demo time if I hopefully I have some
time five minutes I'm going to show you
my demo so this demo you can also find
on this s code it will bring you to
GitHub reos 3 if you like the demo
please put some Stars it will help me to
understand like if it's useful for you
or not or provide some feedback for the
application thanks a lot let me jump on
my to the Showcase and I need to stop my
sharing and reshare the whole screen
just a moment so let me share my full
screen and we are good to go let's
how we go entire screen
and uh so we go I Was preparing this
demo uh yeah as you can see I'm I'm
going to show you now um this dropbox
application demo uh you you saw already
at the beginning of my slides doing my
showcases assume that you have Dropbox
account and usually upload some
documents or you can just sometimes it's
like uh put a copy of your documents in
order to not to lose or you can access
from many uh devices from anywhere right
I usually I'm a developer Advocate I
travel a lot I go to conferences and for
me it's one of the terrible thing is to
uh submit invoices for the company who
is paying for for my travel right and
then what you do what I do I need to
collect all the invoices and I need to
do some calculations so what if I have
this intern data which is not visible to
anyone I can use the AI to some somewhat
summarize my expenses and provide some
report for me uh because I don't want to
how to say to spend my time for this so
I start to build this application with a
simple idea as you can see in uh in the
the Dropbox Source Tool The Source Code
also looks very simple you can have a
look the same like uh the same the run
run code is looks like very similar to
Rack approach we are just reading the
documents internally we are chuning it
and these chunks are send it to vector
and B and so on uh and we have also UI
application which is simply streamed
that makes available this sear
searchable functionality on the UI
because I'm not a UI expert because I
don't want to spend my time for the UI
you just can use a stream need to
achieve that let me show you this
application can run let's say uh by poor
python or you can use maybe the tools
like a Docker because we have two
components front end and back end right
I'm running this Docker application
using uh Docker desktop and on Windows
it's terrible on the Windows sometimes
but it's good it's working I'm running
false API and UI as you can see if you
if I open now UI application it will
bring me to Dropbox uh as you can see
here on the screen this is my uh the
dashboard and and I have some files
invoices uploaded on Dropbox and I can
say uh show my all expenses uh from the
previous period and then it should show
me some of my expenses here here we go
as you can see data is coming very fast
uh even if like okay we upload all the
documents you can give a try also by
deleting and Dropbox files and upload
again it takes only three or five four
seconds to process you can already ask
question for example like can
additionally put like show my all
experiences from all invoices and it
should able to summarize somewhat your
invoices and not always but you can see
uh some summarization uh from the input
or you can maybe specify like from
documents sometimes because I have not
only invoices I have also the receipts
available yeah here we go as you can see
I have the booking receipts invoices and
some flight tickets and so on maybe I
can also ask in the future to improve my
application please maybe create some
dashboard create a report PDF or create
an invoice for the company so that I can
easily send so this is simply my
application had to uh find ret receive
some useful information from Dropbox I
hope you like it let me switch back to
my presentation this was everything what
I want to show you now I'm going to back
to my slides in a
moment uh just a moment
uh
yep yeah there you go so if you if you
like the demo you can freely uh check uh
my uh the the qu code and then it will
it will bring you to the applications I
said so takeaways from this session uh
so as we understood there are some
challenges on building application but
if you're using the tools like uh open
source or non open source that makes
your life easier especially in Python
like you can also use a pathway
technology or LM app to combine with
your existing data pipelines or you can
even use existing libraries in Python
without any issues as you have we are
trying to build provide more examples
with the LM application like we did the
stream need example and in the future
maybe some more serious examples like
how you can run your application in the
cloud or how we can bring some
Enterprise data and so on so with that
that was my uh presentation is about
thank you for your attention and happy
upcoming Merry Christmas I hope you
receive one blessing after another this
coming year wish you also happy holidays
a new year that makes you smile every
day thanks a lot and we can jop to qu
session let me check if you have any
question in the
chat going to say we got two minutes um
it looks looks like there's no questions
yet but anyone who's on um feel free to
drop those in there no I have a question
like while I was speaking I don't see
myself in the camera do you see
myself um I do not see you in the
comment it's interesting because uh the
camera is switching off very
frequently uh I was I don't know I don't
know if it's because of system because I
the my camera always was on but uh
it's not showing on your
side um I'm
not another question is there a GitHub
repo for
that oh do we did we lose
you um on my side
H all right yeah yeah I think we I think
we lost you for a quick second um there
is one question though they want to know
if there's a GitHub repo for the
app uh yeah yeah qu code maybe I will
drop my presentation this is a Christmas
style presentation and you can check uh
or I can drop directly here okay okay
thank you I think alisandra shared it
already in chat phenomenal yeah I was
going to say we could also take it to
Discord as well um I think the yeah I'm
taking it I'm bringing on
Discord